[Musique]
la saison cyclonique 2018 a débuté le
1er juin dernier après celle de l'an
dernier qui a quand même vu irma est
marié à fracasser une bonne partie de
notre région caraïbe ont jour yvelines q
c'est dangereux vous êtes membre du
comité des assureurs antilles guyane
notamment de la commission dommage
eh bien tu sais faut-il encore une fois
rappelé la nécessité d'être assuré qu'on
soient particuliers ou qu'on soit
entreprise
oui c'est une nécessité et c'est une
mesure de protection de ses biens enfin
il fait partie des mesures de protection
de ses biens est ce que tout le monde
est assurée malheureusement dans nos
contrées ça n'est pas toujours le cas en
a quand même une bonne partie de la
population qui reste sans assurance sont
expliqués se ferait pourquoi on refuse
pourquoi enrichi niel s'assurer parce
que pour certains l'assurance coûte cher
pour d'autres ils pensent qu'ils n'ont
jamais rien eu ils n'auront jamais rien
ou à mon avis c'est prendre un risque
sur le futur concernant notamment la
survenance d'événements naturels et puis
un certain nombre de personnes restent
sans assurance parce qu'ils ne trouvent
pas l'assureur on retrouve le sourire
non ils ne vont pas trouver d'assureurs
parce que ils ont des risques par
exemple qui sont situées en bordure de
mer aux habitations en bordure de mer on
va y arriver
la saison puisqu'elle vient de débuter
est ce qu'il est trop tard pour
s'assurer non il n'est pas trop tard
vous pouvez vous assurer jusqu'à la
prévision qui nous met en alerte orange
les souscriptions s'arrête nous sommes
le dit jean que mercredi en cyclone
risque de frotter c'est la martinique je
vais courir m'assurer dès lors qu' on
n'a pas pris de mesures d' alerte orange
que doit-on assuré tout d'abord pour les
particuliers alors le particulier qui
soit propriétaire ou locataire doit
souscrire ce qu'on appelle une multi
risques habitation dont qui comprend des
garanties de dommages et dès lors que le
contrat comporte des garanties dommages
tels que l' incendie
il a automatiquement la couverture
d'événements naturels et les
catastrophes naturelles
pour le particulier aussi j'ajouterai
que pour l'automobile puisqu'on sait
très bien que en cas d'inondation on
peut perdre son automobile
il est bon de s'assurer que on a une
garantie de dommages dans son contrat
sinon si on est assurée uniquement aux
tiers comme les gens aiment à le dire
ici c'est à dire en responsabilité
civile
la voiture l'autre il faut surtout
éviter par exemple de jeu optimal avec
l'assureur c'est à dire que une faute
pour le papier beaucoup il faut il ne
faut pas sous-estimer souvient
exactement là aussi c'est une précaution
et là je m'adresse à toutes les
personnes qui sont déjà assurés
c'est qu'il faut quand même penser à
vérifier ces garanties le montant des
capitaux assurés je parle aussi pour les
professionnels et vérifier que ce qu'on
a déclaré à l'assureur lors de la
conclusion du contrat correspond à la
réalité actuelle
parce que là aussi suite à ce sinistre
il peut y avoir des réductions au niveau
des indemnités c'est à dire aussi pour
la coupe du monde je décide de changer
d'écran de taille d'écran de ce truc
plus grand que chez moi et avec le grand
allié américain qui pourraient non il
faudrait en fait il ya vraiment une très
grande différence au niveau de la valeur
des contenus pour les particuliers ça va
encore passer je m'adresse surtout
professionnels qui sous-estiment des
fois leurs marchandises les entreprises
oui alors les entreprises là aussi on
dénote réticence à s'assurer non en
général un professionnel une entreprise
qui est souvent le cas terrain du fonds
de commerce des fois ils sont pas
propriétaires des bâtiments en général a
pour souci de protéger son outil de
travail
la seule chose ils oublient souvent de
garantir ce qu'on appelle les pertes
d'exploitation suite à survenance
notamment de l'incendié ou d'un cyclone
que cette garantie poser problème
sous-entendu par ça l'assurance des
pertes d'exploitation va permettre à
l'assuré d'obtenir une indemnisation
pour la sa perte de chiffre d'affaires
pendant le temps d'arrêt de l'activité
c'est pas seulement le remboursement par
exemple des machines curium là on est
sur des dommages directs des dommages
matériels
alors vous devez parler de quelque chose
de très précis tout à l'heure la
localisation par exemple pour les
particuliers aussi pour les entreprises
vridi à condition de trouver un assureur
qui acceptent de belles d'assurer tout
simplement il ya des ddd des conditions
pour être assuré oui en fait c'est une
des grandes règles disons qui régit
notre industrie l'assureur pratique ce
qu'on appelle la sélection des risques
un risque doit demeurer disons pour
qu'ils soient assurables
il faut commun qui présente un certain
nombre de caractères c'est à dire une
certaine dose de d'incertitude dans la
survenance du dommage donc
résultat des courses en pratique si on
sait notamment par rapport aux
événements passés que dans une zone
le risque d'inondation est récurrent
l'assureur va rechigné à vous assurer
c'est à dire sur la le bourg de
rivière-pilote on mourra de très grosses
difficultés de plus en plus difficile je
ne dis pas que tout le monde va refuser
mais je sais qu'un certain nombre vont
demander c'est ce qu'on appelle la
déclaration des antécédents si vous
déclarez que vous avez été inondées à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu une pluie ou une
onde tropicale etc
l'assureur soyez vous fera payer une
prime extrêmement élevé que vous ne
pourrez pas payer soit elle va vous
refusez c'est un droit de l'assureur
c'est ce qu'on appelle la sélection des
risques et autre chose aussi c'est que
on peut s'assurer mais faut-il encore
qu'on est un bien qui donc présente
notamment un certain nombre de de
respect notamment au niveau des normes
de construction
oui enfin par exemple toute cette série
de restaurant qu'on a par exemple sur le
littoral du carbet qui régulièrement son
sont prises d'assaut par la houle
non non ils ne vont pas trouver
d'assureurs donc ils le font à leurs
risques et périls oui c'est à dire qu'en
fait à mon avis ils prennent une partie
de leurs bénéfices pour pouvoir s'auto
assurer l'auto assurance existe mais
faut-il encore avoir les moyens
puisqu'en général après la survenance
d'une catastrophe
il arrive à se remettre en activité et
tous ces coureurs qui sont par exemple
dans le centre ville de fort-de-france
en bordure de mer pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas eu de d'inondations
récurrentes sur le bourg enfin le centre
ville de fort de france
parce qu'il ya eu quand même les travaux
les collectivités aussi doivent
s'intéresser à ce problème le curage des
rivières là tout à l'heure j'entendais
aux nouvelles le problème de la cmr on
sait très bien d'où ses venues
l'inondation et point même de rivière il
se trouvait par derrière donc voilà et
dans la définition d'ailleurs des
catastrophes naturelles
on vous dit que en fait il faut que
toutes les mesures pour empêcher la
survenance de dommages aient été prises
sauf que les catastrophes naturelles
sont de plus en plus nombreux sont de
plus en plus violents vous voyez on peut
faire pour anticiper cela est bien ses
protégés entretenir sa maison parce que
on va pas empêcher l'événement naturel
d'arrivée mais ce qu'on peut encore
empêcher c'est la survenance d'un
dommage relativement important par
exemple vous devez entretenir vos
chesneau vos gouttières vérifier
l'étanchéité de vos terrasses de vos
toitures
ça c'est dallas pour le particulier pour
l'entreprise exactement et les
martiniquais le fonds n'a c'est un blanc
y remédier et maria en coûtait pour les
assurances
un peu plus de 2 milliards 2009 155
millions d'euros au niveau mondial les
experts s'attendent à une envolée des
primes à cause de cette multiplication
des phénomènes
turrel que nous que nous venons
d'évoquer
cela va engendrer forcément une
augmentation de l'assurance
oui oui oui il y aura une augmentation
des primes d'assurance puisque derrière
cette augmentation
il faut savoir que tous les compagnies
d'assurance ont leur propre assurance
qu'on appelle la réassurance ils ce sont
les réassureurs qui vont augmenter parce
que au-delà d'un certain montant de
dommages c'est la réassurance qui prend
le relais et donc comme toute industrie
c'est sûr que s'ils ont eu à payer vont
augmenter les prix maison de fable qui
sera applicable à tout de suite ça sera
applicable cette année il ya déjà des
augmentations qui sont en cours de toute
façon un certain nombre d'assurés ont vu
leurs primes augmenter alors vous dites
aussi que lorsqu'on cherche à s'assurer
il faut bien lire les conditions de
l'assurance en général c'est toute
petite ligne corée chine beaucoup à lire
vous a cité tout le monde a vraiment
parcourir sa police d'assurance
oui d'autant plus que maintenant ça fait
partie de nos obligations de conseil et
d'information
donc en principe vous devez lire les
garanties alors en ce qui concerne les
contrats multirisques habitation
professionnels il faut savoir que chaque
compagnie peut avoir des définitions
différentes au niveau de la notion de
bâtiments je m'explique
vous pouvez avoir une notion de
bâtiments restrictive c'est à dire que
bon ça va porter que sur le bâtiment en
lui-même
et puis vous pouvez avoir une définition
du bâtiment qui un peu plus extensive où
on va prendre en compte les portails les
murs de clôture les murs de soutènement
et même les antennes donc là aussi il
faut regarder sa définition parce que
derrière chaque garantie et tchèques
exclusion il peut ça peut expliquer
aussi une différence au niveau des
tarifications toujours du contrat type
ce sont des contrats types mais où la
compagnie au niveau des garanties
contractuelles est libre de donner la
définition qu'elle veut et aussi
faussant la suivre il faut s'en assurer
et est-ce que moi par exemple si je
viens pour évaluer pour assurer un bien
chez vous
je peux mettre quelques clauses qui
serait très particulière très
spécifiques alors non là on est dans des
contrats types
justement vous parliez de contrat type
vous ne pouvez pas dérogé aux conditions
générales du disons qu'ils sont donnés
par par l'assureur
la seule chose si vous avez des clauses
particulières a inséré par exemple si
vous avez une maison qui est construite
en bois et bien ça sera spécifiée au
niveau de ce qu'on appelle des
conditions particulières mais pas la
pression peut-être que les assurances
elle pose un certain nombre de choses et
ceux qui doivent se doivent être assurés
n'ont qu'à prendre ce travail puis il
c'est fini alors c'est pour ce qui est
de la clientèle de particuliers c'est ce
qu'on appelle les contrats d'adhésion à
adhésion mais de toute façon la
législation prévue par la cpr prévoit
une protection de l'assuré c'est
l'autorité de résolution prudentielles
en fait c'est notre gendarme s'étagent
entre le gendarme de l'industrie des
assurances et des banques
et il est prévu une protection de
l'assuré c'est à dire qu'avant de
souscrire un contrat de type donc comme
vous le dites pour les multirisques
habitation ils les nécessaires de
conseiller son client et de l'informer
ne peut pas on peut pas se vendre un
contrat d'assurance sans qu'il y ait au
préalable
c'est un stade disant d'explication à
n'assurer ça peut arriver qu'une
assurance décide de se retirer de marché
tout simplement parce que le jeu n'en
vaut pas la chandelle financièrement oui
c'est arrivé par le passé notamment
suite à des gros événements qui avaient
frappé notamment saint martin et saint
martin des assurances ce sont aussi tous
se retrouver une grosse banny oui oui je
perds trop d'argent déboursé lorsqu'il
se passe quelque chose
ben tiens à ce que le risque peut-être
n'en vaut pas la chandelle c'est à dire
pour le montant des primes collectées ce
qu'ils ont déboursé étaient trop élevés
et tant pis pour celui qui veut
entreprendre qui ne trouve pas d'autres
contrats d'assurance pourtant
nécessaires pour la reprise de son
activité alors le conseil que je
donnerais en fait il existe
il existe une cartographie des risques
naturels notamment des zones
géographiques impacté par tel ou tel
phénomène naturel pour l'instant le
risque le plus important pour nous c'est
l'inondation
on n'a pas encore connu la submersion
marine dont dieu merci
donc mon conseil c'est avant de
s'installer
il faut quand même consulté cette carte
ya un plan notamment un qui est fait au
niveau des communes il faut consulter et
en fonction de la zone s'installer ou
pas voilà c'est le grand conseil que je
donnerais au jour d'aujourd'hui
merci d'avoir été avec nous et d'une
cuisson rappelle que vous êtes de la
commission dommage de du comité des
assureurs antilles guyane merci
d'arrêter avec nos bonnes journées
[Musique]